[Music]  prince michael jackson admits he did not  inherit his late father's musical  abilities  don't expect a hit record from prince  michael jackson in the near future in a  new interview the 20 year old says he'll  carry on his father's legacy in other  ways can you sing i can't sing i can't  dance i can't do any of that yeah  there's no way i can even be a part of  it  no no i've tried and it's embarrassing  yeah it's embarrassing we can't even  talk about that  [Music]  my dream is to do film it's all this  song to integrate them together like  it's never been done before that's what  i  my heart is set up thankfully the king  of pop did pass down his passion for  film to his eldest son i do video  production and most of it has been music  videos  [Music]  and his philanthropic spirit as he  continues his heel world legacy with  hill la i was all thanks to my dad he  raised me right  [Music]